[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
I have not been this pissed ever in my
life but no 1867 past my roll call in
the Senate
this bill basically states that envelope
rights doesn't mean [ __ ] those of you
out there who don't give a [ __ ] about
what's going on in our government
because it's too complicated well let me
go ahead and break the [ __ ] down for you
we're title of this bill is the National
Defense Authorization Act senators of
the United States let me ask you
something do you think that just because
you write something on the title that
makes it sound like it's good for us
that we oughta bet you can believe it
you dumb shits people let me break this
down for you one more time I want you to
listen carefully if this bill is not be
told you know that thing the
Constitution that protects your rights
is [ __ ] like that
it doesn't get matter anymore so let's
go in to see what's up with the
situation
LG Asda let Guinea good outsiders before
you let's boil this down one more time
as simple turns to give you a gist of
what's going on if this bill goes
through it allows our federal government
on American soil to detain American
citizens without trial or charge at the
discretion of the president let me break
it down one more time just in case you
didn't hear this you know that [ __ ] that
was given to you and down on the
Constitution the Bill of Rights it
doesn't mean [ __ ] kids a few bullet
points for you you're suspected of being
a terrorist you can either be detained
taken away or even at certain points
assassinated if need be American
citizens key word here suspect it down
well but I'll doing this until proven
guilty
not anymore [ __ ] and this [ __ ] goes
through whatever the federal government
categorizes as terrorists like conduct
your ass is gonna be going to Guantanamo
Bay my Middle Eastern brothers and
sisters you thought it was hard giving
it to a [ __ ] airport [ __ ] thank you
walking to a McDonald's Korean people no
one can tell jokes because you just
might be his cousin African people you
[ __ ] I don't know but you better watch
ass to your old ass boy Senator John
McCain wants to declare American soil as
a military battlefield he's gonna love
this NES you something foo on all of our
military out there protecting this
country so we don't have to bring it
home oh yes sméagol looking ass mother
you want to turn our homeland into a war
zone you want to insert military into
our domestic law enforcement are you
kidding me right now Senator McCain
stands there like the ancient ass
Billick that he is bringing up all these
old facts about World War two and Nazis
and how there were American citizens
helping them out [ __ ] y'all tell me so
in the past few decades our national
security but we had dis millions and
millions of dollars in to has not
approved since then
Senator McCain I understand this accused
different age gap between us you've
experienced a lot your best friend
growing up was Fred Flintstone dinosaur
the shoes weren't invented at the time
back in your day you were a hunter and
gatherer the biggest invention in your
time was the wheel but the next time you
come up with some argument stick no game
up son about man offend me help you out
of hearing you bill for you that you
might want to pass it's called if you're
over oh shut the Kazan people due
process will not exist for you
what is due process due process like
that home why on the block that protects
you and your individual rights from the
bigger home on the block that wants to
lock you up
you know when you watch cops in law and
order and people be getting the rest of
this [ __ ] and all this and they say
stuff like you have a right to an
attorney
you have the right to remain silent you
know your Miranda rights that [ __ ] wall
exists now the only thing that's gonna
be said to you is get ready for
Guantanamo copy sandwich all the way
essentially our government is going to
be given an incredible amount of
authority without restraint let me tell
you something all of these immigrants
did not swim all these miles across the
ocean to go to a country that's just
like theirs if this [ __ ] goes down how
much swim my fat head back to Asia I
love this country and the freedoms and
rights that are a lot to me by being an
American citizen and now there's a
possible
that's also to be shipped away what's
the whole point of developing the
democratic government and developing a
constitution and a bill of rights to
protect us and create a balance between
government and people what the Capon to
you 93 senators that voted on this [ __ ]
did you somehow forget it along the way
of being a politician you know the
American dream to me has never been
about making money fame or being in the
spotlight it has been about the freedom
of choice and living in a country where
that supports you that your government
supports your rights as a human being I
love this country too much not to say
anything about this [ __ ] so for those of
you who want to complain and do nothing
well just sit that real tight as tight
and FPSO cuz you bout to get ready to
get
[Music]